[Music]
[Music]
everybody's a 20 billion dollar
compound i am go
maga
enthusiast and uh chief and mega
enthusiasm
joined by the uh hunky
large small-headed
excuse
excuse me excuse me fake news did we
prove that i probably proved it was
slightly under average
that's i heard that it was
slightly many people are many people are
saying
thank you thank you but but we know you
have a big beautiful brain in there even
though your head is slightly under
all i'm saying is many people were
saying like they prefer that it's like
average or slightly below average size
really they prefer that yeah many people
people are saying folks
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
welcome everybody thank you for joining
us today's episode of
sponsoredbystamps.com
hassan welcome this is
we're going to be doing this show and
then you'll be gone for two weeks that
is an announcement with yes in love
i will uh i will be heading out to [ __ ]
camp with some of my friends where we
will be doing uh a bunch of you know
uh interesting content relay races
tug of war that sort of thing we just
like to do it once a year
potato sack race maybe i like that it's
a good idea
you can come next time you'll come egg
drop egg drop
i don't know i have no idea i don't have
like the uh you know the american camp
uh experience as much as like most other
people do so we'll see we'll see what
happens it's a lot of fun then i'm gonna
go to new york fashion week
but it's more so why did you do that
it's just that i am gonna be i was
looking for a week
to be in new york regardless so i could
do a bunch of podcasts there
you know we're setting some up with like
andrew schultz and whatnot and a bunch
of other podcasts out there yeah that's
cool because i'm trying to promo um my
other podcast for your hand mm-hmm
just saying
nothing after yeah just for your end
right yeah leaves you hanging yeah by
the way people in the chat are saying
you look skinny and i agree
okay that's nice to know i think
if i can just be
i have been trying but that's nice the
sh i'm wearing a smaller shirt which i
think makes me look slim from here up so
something is working for me but olivia
has uh
you look good you look good
it feels like
you look like you you didn't have frozen
pizza this week nope
i'm on a journey my friend i'm on a
weight loss journey and it shows thank
you brother
thank you yes so okay
well
have fun on your journeys
yeah i uh we'll you'll be missed but
let's have a let's go out with a banger
uh we've got a lot to talk about first
of all
real quickly
uh teddyfish.com thank you uh
our full collection it's 107 degrees
outside
if you're at a hoodie if you're in the
market for a hoodie
that's hot now's the time my friends
there are shorts and short sleeve shirts
these are our classic
yes classic
clean baby
good
classic pigment dye do you want some of
these heston
look at that look at that absolutely i'm
wearing a basic right now i like oh you
are stand-up showdown
oh i love that color which one do you
like purple
honestly i like all of them but this
one's purple are you asking me thanks jb
which one do you like
uh i like khaki
this one okay i'm gonna hook you up with
the full outfit
all right thank you guys that's it
all right thanks
now
i noticed that you went on a mutual
friend of ours super mega's
uh podcast uh friend of the show
you like those guys love them i hate
those guys man matt watson's a friend of
the show actually i don't know al alex
mcgee
is that his ryan
his last name is mcgee that's like a
fake name
you're just that's just south carolina
irish phobia right now i'm just being
real it's like oh
tits mcgee over here you know what i
mean like it's just a meme
he's but okay his name's mcgee yeah
they're wonderful boys i mean they i i
hate him i hate him a lot actually it
was terrible i hated this podcast
oh really don't want don't watch this
podcast
well anyway they did a nice funny little
gag on you here right now oh yeah real
funny
funny gag well hold on
there's something good about it this is
what i got yep
it was made specifically for you
we haven't had something made
specifically for a guest yet nope like a
piece of furniture dedicated to them
they got you a tiny tiny chair
it's like literally ankle level
it does like the the top of the chair
goes it's below your knee it might reach
the does it even reach the top of your
calf
no way no my calf is
have a seat man welcome to the show yeah
i just want to see you sit they didn't
give you an option either right like i
love that no do you satin it the whole
episode well they they actually they
have a couch normally there but they
took it out of the room
and
um
they were like we can bring it back in
the next fabric i was like nah i'm gonna
sit through it yeah
you've gone this far yeah
they forced poor hassan to sit in this
tiny chair and here at the a street
podcast leftovers 20 billion dollar
studio we have a budget
and we had got mad respect for you
so to co to counter their absolute
disgrace we have brought a throne
befitting a king you want me to sit on
this
what why would you even ask that i don't
know if
i feel like i mean no spoilers but i
feel like it's the throne you know i
mean it's the iron throne okay yeah yeah
well what if i'm not worthy oh you're
you're worthy i sit on it i sit on it
it's gonna [ __ ] start cutting me and
[ __ ] nope it's all cushioned fine
leather uh
[Music]
what do we think this chair has a lot of
lore on the show so
this is this is wonderful okay
i feel great i feel like uh okay it
feels right
yeah we wouldn't do that to you we mean
[ __ ] those guys for that yeah
and uh
we're gonna celebrate you today
so there's that by the way we were a
little bit late because uh you were
doing a little bit of a covert test for
yourself i was yeah you're clear yeah i
lied actually it's fake as a false
positive you have a thick one in your
pocket yeah i had a fake one that'd be
slick
um
19 it's not even like i know whenever i
get sick and i never get sick but when i
when i do feel a little icky i guess
if i have like a sore throat or whatever
immediately i'm like all right gotta get
checked up for kobe make sure it's not
covered it's kind of weird getting
something else in this day and age when
you get yeah you're like
what happened [ __ ] is this what do we do
about it
yeah at the top of the show we need to
talk about our friend banks now hassan
and dan have a undying and even love
have undying love and respect for banks
blanks
but banks hosted a party for rick caruso
what the [ __ ] what do we do about this
okay well you're cucking me right now
how so because he called me after this
he did he did what he did and he's like
you know you're like kind of plugged in
you're like a plugged in guy in the
politics
and you know this was like a crazy event
that i was at and i just wanted to get
your perspective and also like if you're
into it like maybe come on the next uh
meeting and whatever and i was like oh
yeah no i love that i love i mean i was
i was honest i didn't lie to him i
wasn't like i hate
i wasn't like i love rick caruso he's
the best i definitely would vote for him
but i was like listen
i was honest with him i said why don't
you tell him about rick caruso i told
him that i'm not the biggest fan and i
think that his method of dealing with
homelessness and and crime is is pretty
pretty awful uh
but that uh his opponent karen pass is
not necessarily great either okay okay
and these are an endorsement for rick
caruso unexpected from well definitely
not an endorsement but i would like to
go to one of these things and uh you
know
hear a little bit further from the man
i'm an open-minded guy can i offer a
perspective
what
if face blank is at a
political event and they want him
involved
no recruiting not a great event no no
rick caruso is tanking pretty pretty
hard right he's like yo you know whose
endorsement we need faze banks um he's
definitely not doing great
uh he has the endorsement of pretty much
every los angeles celebrity
uh why is that why is that is he paying
them he's
incred insanely rich yeah so rick caruso
for those who aren't aware he's running
for mayor of l.a he spent more on any
mayor race in the history of all mayor
races in the united states he's spent
like 20 million or by now who knows how
much
but every tv ad is completely saturated
with rick caruso
man's trying to buy the election
and um
why is chat is saying hassan is king and
ethan is little hand king why is he king
no little hand of the king like
yeah
i think i got a little
hands i got a little thing with the yeah
yeah and dang it
the thing about karen bass is that like
she's a she's a unique person obviously
um
she's progressive presenting as i would
like to call it but isn't necessarily
she's very much a california progressive
california progressives are like gavin
newsom they uh they they do a show of
force and they're like yeah you should
not execute trans uh kids on site
and then it's
good then and then they're like and then
the republicans will be like oh my god i
can't believe you said that that's gay
and you're crazy or communist but then
when it comes down to it they're like
there's a second part to it where it's
like unless they're homeless on the
street you know what i mean in which
case you should do that is there is
usually the california progressive
uh attitude towards sort of thing
homelessness is a massive problem in
this state in most states uh it is
directly caused by drum roll ironic uh
people like rick crew so real estate
developers oh i'm sorry i was
a quick roll it's okay he causes the
problem on one hand yeah and on the
other hand
blames them i think we need to turn
homeless people and i've been saying
this for a long time and maybe it's time
i've run on this platform yeah we need
to turn them into glue we need to
appreciate yeah
okay you're running on the republican
ticket
we need to highly process their bones
yeah their bone marrow and turn it into
some kind of gelatin or glue substance
and so that it can help society
a lot of these people
yes a great platform i think like then
you make money you sell them i think it
was more socially acceptable like
someone and maybe it will become more
socially acceptable in like the next 10
years someone will run on like hunting
homeless people for sport as a platform
well that is interesting for you should
raise money for the city too if you have
permits yeah exactly like conservation
style the greatest time i mean when you
when you see the way people talk about
homeless people like they just do not
recognize it as a as a
byproduct of a inherently flawed system
and instead people who have uh who are
immoral somehow like they were immoral
and they were punished in this most
protestant way or
they were immoral
uh because they're poor and that's
that's how it works
it's funny when i hear people like joe
rogan and people who are like i fled
california because there's just too much
homeless
i'm run it's like they're running from
the homeless people like bro joe rogan
wherever the [ __ ] you live there's no
there's no homeless people i guarantee
that well he he moved to austin
ironically uh as as many like as some
rich people that wanted to avoid income
tax because they're [ __ ] brokies
unlike me and ethan right here with top
g's real top g's we pay 14
we don't care we're not [ __ ] brokeys
we don't have to run away to austin
texas that's what we don't pay exactly i
don't drink government water okay and i
[ __ ] pay my state i don't run from it
yeah you know who's funding the police
us we are right we are suck a little bit
yeah suck a little bit of dick more
people if more people were like joe
rogan then the police would be defunded
i'm a man of god
anyway but yeah speaking of top g yeah
he
i haven't talked about it but yeah he he
sent me a cease and desist i [ __ ] i
saw
i haven't showed the document yet
or talked about it i
oh you were holding it off for your good
podcast no we could talk about i mean i
brought it up
i'm waiting for a little more details
i'll probably talk about it on monday
because i have this great title like
andrew tate is
suing me or something you know but yeah
his demand he sent he sent our lawyers a
cease and desist
demanding
within 24 hours we remove all content
talking about him and all my tweets and
not mention many more and what the best
part he said within 24 hours it went to
my attorney spam box which is
interesting for three days oh so you
so
oops
so that's the the thing i love about
that is like
i think he's like that's like fighter
mentality right you got to go for the
title you got to go for the belt uh uh
haver like you are
you have a you have a you have a legal
precedent taught in law school for like
you know your two-time uh victory now
yep in the online legal space that's
true so i think that's why he came after
you because he's like i gotta go after
the top g the top g of being sued
well i was like i'll be honest andrew um
i'm way out of your league on that one
yeah i was about to say i'm not much of
a fighter but when it comes to lawsuits
i'm [ __ ] yeehaw baby yeah that's what
i'm saying it's like he he didn't
realize that he's like swinging way
above his weight he
with the weakest jabs too it's like you
have to delete all mentions of me with
the [ __ ] you can't do that
it was obvious the term ck if i wasn't
gonna or at least he doesn't know
anything about me if he thought that
would scare me then that's that's pretty
sad
shut up he keeps saying he keeps saying
i'm a
bisexual armenian genocide denier so
um well that seems like defamation in
the same way that he's saying i defamed
him he's like i'm not a human trafficker
i was like google and you take human
trafficker and then tell a judge that i
defamed you also like
also if there's an ongoing thousand
ongoing investigations exactly what do
you mean yeah you can't
so that would be a really that would be
a really interesting court case though
because like
don't you have to seal stuff i mean
don't you have to unseal certain
documents or at least like yeah in
discovery like a lot of interesting
things would be brought to light i don't
think this case would ever get to a
discovery because it would be an easy
anti-slap
but the anti-slap briefs would be
[ __ ] fascinating because
everything
that
you know he says i can't say about him
is going to be entered into the public
record and great
depths probably more
greater depths than has been discussed
publicly
and it's going to be a it's going to be
fantastic yeah i think he's just like
trying to maintain clout that's why he
came after you you think
yeah because you're
you're like uh you're like a good you're
like a
lightning rod for that sort of thing you
know his his fans hate my guts yeah but
i think part of one of the main tweets
he
one of the first things and the main
things he mentioned is
this tweet that got like over 300 000
likes i think he didn't like this
no
i'm going down here yadda yadda yadda
we're about to get sued by the 12 g
yeah so brave to have this sex
trafficking violent misogynist r word on
i didn't realize that this thing would
pop off but damn i got 311 000 likes bro
what the [ __ ] so it popped off and i
think that just he wasn't he wasn't
happy about that
shut the [ __ ] up it's unattractive
but i just the whole thing is so ironic
i think the worst part about that is
that he looks like such a [ __ ] in this
dude that's what i'm saying when he this
angle makes him look like a weirdo bro i
mean he always looks like a weirdo but
this is this one makes him worse than a
weirdo a betta yeah yeah yeah he's got
the one he's got the he looks like the
no [ __ ] aliens like totally that's
what we see
[ __ ] yeah he's like why are you
why are you signing off from your
bathroom
like why are you
it looks like wait i don't know what
yeah wait or maybe that's a [ __ ]
racing chair he put a dx racer in his
bathroom to talk to tucker carlson like
that's not pope g behavior yeah we joke
that he lives in a race car bed yeah
it's not everyone sleeps in a race car
it's not top g behavior but what's more
beta than being like stop talking about
me well bugatti is the ultimate beta car
i need you to stop talking about me
so i mean speech for me but you need to
stop talking i mean shut up [ __ ] this
man is
this man contradicts himself on on the
regular it's it's not
it's not surprising to me that he went
from like oh it's free speech it's time
for free speech we need to do free
speech and then turn around and go not
like that not like the way you're doing
it i don't like the way you're doing the
free speech exactly and his fans will
say oh well free speech doesn't protect
you lying about people
well
i ain't lying bro he is being just again
this is all facts bruh this is all facts
and it's well within my right to say it
okay yeah so i just want to hear from
all the speech free speech champions
that were riding for him so hard when he
got banned yeah exactly no platform
you like that i like that i i made that
joke as well it's just like
i mean but they're always like this
this is how this is how they are it's
just everyone is so hypocritical about
research at least i'm honest i'm like
yeah i think that certain things do not
fall within the confines of free speech
everyone has that same exact opinion
it's just that like for a lot of people
that just means like hate speech and
consequences from saying hate speech
should be protected and i disagree with
that even though i probably get hit with
hate speech violations way more than
most of these other [ __ ] idiots do
um you know there was this one tweet it
was like
dude you look you dress gay like hassan
[ __ ] came to america because if he if
he dressed the way he does right now
like he'd be thrown off of a roof in
turkey like they're saying like you know
turkey muslim country isis i'm gay
pejorative right
and i i quote tweeted and i said no i
came to america to [ __ ] your mom and she
loved it to be honest i saw that and and
then they were like trying to get me a
[ __ ]
ah
you know oh the german thing yeah i love
when i get it i'm like bro come on
you're literally a nazi
i love when i get those those are my
faves yeah he that guy who said that had
like
another tweet where he was like i miss
him so bad and the person he missed so
bad was hitler yeah
we miss
we miss you bro
[Laughter]
but i want to hear people like
all the commentary channels
modahar jake paul who were like yo i
don't [ __ ] ride with him but i write
with free speech it's like you talk
about this bro that's youtube that's
youtube that's the youtube mentality
everyone on youtube you know that's the
[ __ ] stuff the only person who cares
about free speech on youtube is me
i'm the [ __ ] and i don't consider you on
youtube but yeah
well now you are with me yeah but you're
twitcher i'm the i declaring myself here
and now the king of free speech you
don't understand nobody cares about free
speech like me
i've never sued anybody i have never
compelled speech from anyone i've only
ever defended and philly d by the way
he's a king of free speech i have only
ever defended myself against
by the way i see what you're doing he
put you in another uh thumbo and you're
like oh philly d he's the king of frieza
yeah stop sucking up to him on the floor
yes he is no he he is actually he's did
the god of free speech well he had a
[ __ ] thumb i'm sorry to tell you he
put me in a thumbnail yesterday and i
got another one coming because the
andrew tate news just broke so i've
definitely got one in the pipeline
comics put me next to sorry
sorry bro
but what i do want to say steps up
is that i'm the king of free speech i
have only defended it i have set
precedent after precedent
please sue me philly or [ __ ] not
philly dude don't see me
sue me bro it's great man it's [ __ ]
great i think he's just i i do think
he's just trying to get clouded up from
this though like he's trying to he's
trying to desperately cling on whatever
relevancy he can he sees you as a good
person to like
position himself against you know what i
mean because he sees you as like
a guy that a lot of his fan base would
immediately be like oh [ __ ] him yeah i
hate him you have a lot of clout
and you have a lot of negative cloud as
well
from your many years on the internet uh
so i think that's why he's doing this he
put out a video on me like yo this dude
said the n word and he said all this
mean stuff at like the typical like uh
blooper reel ethan klein boot blooper
reel and it's like we've seen that bruh
we've seen that
in time
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] frustrating
because it's like bro
like
you don't want to live in a world where
people are
incredibly hostile to change you know
what i mean people have the capacity to
change people i have the capacity to get
better people have the capacity to
apologize redeem themselves rehabilitate
themselves it's like and and these
[ __ ] would benefit from that
change is seen as weakness somehow it's
yeah but like sneako for example you
know this kid
he started out as like a really critical
lib fan of bernie sanders
when he was 13 years old he had call of
duty videos that we found where he was
literally talking about like
anti-interventionist strategies in syria
what happened did he lose bro i'm not
even [ __ ] kidding dude i saw those
but like now he's he just seems way
dumber less sharp
i think in a way he is very smart
because i i think
i usually believe that a lot of content
creators know exactly what the [ __ ]
they're doing when they behave when they
portray themselves as like really stupid
or really bigoted i think they know
they're well aware of what they're doing
i think he's just like signaling to a
broader audience
and he saw andrew tates like skyrocket
rise to fame he probably had some
personal motivations as well he has
talked about getting cucked
uh and and how that was like a defining
moment for him i think that probably
played a role in his life where he like
watched his girlfriend get bakakied by
four uh dudes at an orgy is that did
that really happen yeah he's like no no
i'm not making it up
oh you guys didn't know about this no oh
i'm sorry i thought the i thought the
asia issue productions crew knew about
all this i'm not i'm not deep into
sneaker none of us know much about
sneaker i didn't either and then you
know my my hive mind uh that broke
so so was he a participant in the
bukkakee or no
he wasn't from what i understand he went
to like multiple orgies i think he was
like in an open relationship
experimented he seemed like
like he could have gone either way after
that he could have been like very
confident about it but he instead went
like the manosphere red pill route so i
think there was like uh personal
motivators as well that kind of played a
role in his like radicalization his
short radicalization wait tell me more
about the reader
you glossed over that
uh shout out to patrick cc uh who even
though he said i played a role in
sneko's radicalization and i disagree
with him on that
um come on it's gotta be a [ __ ] or
something traumatic no what so he i
didn't really know much about sneko
other than like watching some of his
like one minute podcast or whatever like
his
his like og interviewing random people
on the street [ __ ] that he was doing
and i always thought that there was like
some sussy stuff there like he seemed
like a big like free speech defense hate
speech kind of guy
um
and and um he basically
was never this aggressively like
right-wing manosphere pilled
you know what i mean he was not he was
never this like red-pilled i guess
uh until andrew tate started popping off
and i think he saw that he saw the
success of andrew tate and he was like
oh i could do this this is easy as [ __ ]
right and he probably also personally
had some motivations uh
as well like he personally believes
something
tell me about the bukkakes so they went
to an orgy
do you know for sure like a bunch of
dudes finished on her face like that he
literally talked about it he openly like
this is information can you find that
this is information that you couldn't
extract out of me in a [ __ ] in a
black site okay like the cia could black
bag me put me in a [ __ ] airplane uh
fly me out to egypt and i would not tell
anyone a soul well it's part of his
manosphere story it's part of his
journey but yeah he just
oh yeah so he so this is interesting i
was watching
someone made a video about him and then
i saw
uh
him wearing an h3 shirt that's an l303
shirt yeah and then i saw he made this
video about me
the thumbnail's so good can you pull up
the thumbnail
but it's called um
it's called
h sneko reacts to h3 before he sold his
soul
and then here what let's just listen to
what he says here because we're talking
about the capacity for people to change
is this the time stamp baby
because i can't see
you said it's at 30 seconds that's good
this is good it's time stamp it's it's
part it's muted i can't [ __ ] see the
camera's covering safe space for anyone
wait let me go back i have confrontation
you sit there and get fatter every
single week
again it's like the same thing it's like
batman bad
it's incredible that that's that's
pretty much their only criticism fat man
bad yeah he got fat he hates
i think that's partially what like
breaks a lot of their brains when it
comes to me too because it's like
they're like i can't say he's fat
so that's what he's got that's what they
that's what they get mad at it's like
bro that's not the main thing here you
know what i mean you shouldn't just
worry about that
you know yeah what a is that
it's crazy bro i just went to a random
spot in this video and he's talking
about how i'm fat space because i
promise you h3 i mean my wife hasn't
been cocky in front of me so i have that
going for me that's well i i didn't even
give you the full details i think why
are you holding out
well i was because you pulled the video
okay so let me just do this will never
be a safe space for anyone
what are you saying i wanna i know i
know i don't i don't i know i know i
gotta go back god damn it okay just as
triggered
call us cucks
down vote the video
you're
just for the record you guys on the
right are just as triggered now
as the people on the left everybody's
[ __ ] triggered and what i don't know
are you looking for a safe space guys
are you guys all looking for yep
bro he just outlined his entire theme of
the podcast a safe space where you can't
debate where you can't have
confrontation you sit there and get
fatter every single how's this a safe
space bruh
weird okay
they say this all the time like dude
debates are
debates are pseudo-intellectual sparring
it's it's you know wrestling for for
weirdos who think like it's the primary
form of
showcasing your intellect
or
or testing your metal uh the testing the
metal of your uh you know ideology or
your beliefs in the marketplace of ideas
like no it's just it's just content
and it is just content especially for a
lot of these people who do end up
debating
one another and then become friends with
one another it's like i think that's
[ __ ] gross if you if you hate someone
what the [ __ ] if you hate their
worldview how the [ __ ] are you gonna sit
there and be homies with them you know
especially if they're like a nazi or
some [ __ ] so yeah i mean debating is
more a test of your like
verbal skills than yeah a test 100
because it's all about like got you with
this and what do you say it's like it's
not really it all the time and i do it
all the time i i i don't like doing it i
think it's silly and i think that the
environment that it fosters is really
toxic and not good for learning not good
for
uh making uh better arguments ironically
like educating people about your world
view but all that being true i do have
i've had debates on this so i don't know
what he's talking about but anyway let's
get to the point wait safe space because
i promise you h3h3 productions will
never be a safe space for anyone
for safe space because i promise you
h3h3 productions will never be a safe
space for anyone he's loving this by the
way we're giving him so much we're
giving him so much attention it's fine i
don't care fine i cut through the
[ __ ] and cut through political
affiliation because
[Music]
we'll speak our mind and cut through the
[ __ ] and cut through political
affiliation why are people saying
they're saying that in the chat do you
not see it yeah that's a good there you
go buddy
people that like jews people that do
this kind of content and see like
violent anti-semitism
and they don't
just they don't like do anything i don't
know what the automation tools are on on
youtube to be fair i don't know how easy
it is to moderate youtube but uh you the
same you just say you could yeah no but
this these are your fans bro does that
not disturb you
but anyway
called through political affiliation
speaker w crusaders what the [ __ ] why
are they saying w crusaders my point of
showing this song is that this guy used
to be a bernie sanders fan and he's
acting like a video from seven years ago
in my like enlightened centrist phase
but you aren't saying anything wrong
you're talking about how right-wingers
are also constantly looking for a safe
space no yeah yeah no i was but he's
also i've never claimed that this
podcast is a safe space but i think his
point is look how he's changed he's a
hypocrite but this man changed uh in a
different direction from being a bernie
sanders supporter to being like whatever
the [ __ ] this is now to his girlfriend
getting [ __ ] that's not a political
affiliation i just want to remind him
that that happened now there's anything
wrong with it if you're into it but
clearly a bro sounds like he's not it
broke him yeah
he was conflicted about it but it's like
weird because i've said this before i
don't have an issue with this um i don't
have an issue with repeating this but
like
sneako is uh unlike many of the other
manosphere guys like especially because
he had like a shred of creativity in the
beginning right
he's a creative dude
um
he's also an attractive dude i think um
people will not agree with me on this
but like i think he's like
he's a good-looking guy he could have
just as well if he had like a better
personality if he didn't like go down
this like weird radicalization path like
he could have been like a normal content
creator uh he could have gotten the bag
with mr b stuff instead of trying to
expose mr beast
you know what i mean right
like there were a couple different
turning points in his career it seems
like after watching that patrick cc
video like there were a couple different
turning points in his career that that
basically got him to this point you can
still change your path my friend uh but
changing in his opinion is
change equals hypocrisy which is weird i
always say that conservatives they they
don't believe in change which is weird
is a weird thing i mean you normal human
beings no they love it they love it they
love it when dave rubin changed his
change his politics they love it when
sneaker changed his politics anyway i
want to show this thumbnail look at this
before and after yes a glowing legend
and now a [ __ ] demon
uh zombie and sneaker of course glowing
angelically just like his girlfriend's
face after getting five blue cockies on
it i'm just saying
so so here's the thing here's the thing
here's the thing i'm just saying look at
that so he
he had like a like a relatively open
relationship it seems like from his um
he he
uh mentioned it he had an open
relationship kind of the they went to
orgies together she wanted to go to
orgies and like he pushed for it he well
he makes it seem like she pushed for it
but i think he probably was into it
and i think he still is into it because
like they went to two orgies in one
night
oh that's [ __ ] disgusting how the
[ __ ] do you know
like how do you know two different
orgies happen i'm sorry but they're on
the mailing list look there's nothing
wrong with going to oranges and free sex
and all that and having fun if that's
your cup of tea
great two orgies in one night that's it
i gotta draw the line that's too much
too many orgies man too much bro how
many that's too much dude you gotta you
gotta chill so keep going keep going
tell me what yeah that's that's what he
said uh mm-hmm so
you know he he said basically that uh
watching his girlfriend get [ __ ] by
another dude was similar to like
getting robbed
like he felt like that was that was a
similar experience to him
but then he also went to like multiple
orgies after that
yeah they stayed there they kept doing
it or you know and then they went to
another orgy they went to two orgies in
one night or whatever and it made it
seem he made it seem like that was like
a defining moment for him
and that really changed his perspective
which is weird because like you could
have been like i didn't like this
experience i don't want to do this
anymore
and then been a healthy person or you
could have been like i like this
experience and you know i liked it i
enjoyed it and i'm gonna continue doing
it and be a healthy person it's just a
matter of like confidence versus
insecurity than the way you carry
yourself through these sorts of
interactions
um
and i think that's the defining
strategy of wait well hold on that's the
funny strategy of like a lot of the man
of spirit content creators is that they
just basically
use their insecurity as a selling point
to attract a gigantic audience of also
very insecure if not more insecure men
they don't see that about themselves
yeah
it's very weird they they think that
like but it's so obvious the fake it
till you make it over the top confidence
uh that they present themselves or over
the top masculinity that they that they
present is like um an adequate way to to
overcome the insecure allegations which
you're not beating those i think
and
yeah i mean andrew tate if you look up
to this guy and i know sneko does
because i watch this video about him uh
he is a deeply deeply irr
unsolvably insecure man i mean clearly
clearly just damaged damaged man uh uh
from the bottom of his soul but you say
he had saw someone have sex with his
girlfriend did he in fact
was there a [ __ ] on her face
he said there were four dicks
four decks all pointed at her
girlfriend's face at his girlfriend oh
that's okay but yeah so so that's a lot
to take in if that's not something that
you're ready for yeah i think it broke
him but i think he literally but i think
he did end up like
like it could have been so wonderful
like he could have just literally been
like
there are two ways out of this could
have been like i didn't like it i
realized it's not for me and i want to
maintain like a monogamous relationship
don't even know if it's possible after
that
to continue being in a monogamous
relationship with that same person
maybe it is i don't know
or you could have just been like
this is something that i'm this is
something i'm into i like it
and and just been normal about it you
know what i mean and promoted it and
been like it's not for everybody it's
not everyone's cup of tea but i don't
personally care i get to [ __ ] all these
other girls like you know what i mean
i'm into it i like it it sounds usually
when you do that kind of thing you ease
into it right like i've heard couples
they go and they watch at first
and they see if they're but it sounds
like they just went straight to the uh
i'll tell you this
i've been knowing orgy you have been i
went to an orgy uh in the hands is this
breaking news no i've talked about this
before i went to an orgy in the hamptons
and like i did not participate because
in my mind i was thinking like
an orgy is gonna be like a like a maybe
not like an eyes wide shut scenario but
like in movies you see it in a certain
way like and you know
the lighting
and the camera angles
and the the way that every actor and
actress looks right is very different
than a real orgy in real life because
there's also smell-o-vision when you're
[ __ ] out there
okay spilled coffee all over i i know
you got so excited about the orgy thing
you [ __ ] i just put concrete on
myself yeah
how dunk
smells uh
when it's when it's in your when it's
happening in front of you not great um
people can like come up to you and try
to you know try to make out with you or
whatever that's not great either when i
was like uh no i'm good um because you
weren't attracted to them or no i was
not okay okay and also just like
you know everyone was like uh like a
norman you know what i mean and they
were no matter and no matter how hot
people are yeah if
you
are not watching something through a
camera angle that is like perfectly
positioned
it's just not going to look as good
right you know what i mean it's just not
the same the reality is never as good as
no it's not so i was like this is not
for me
hold on let me know back
i went with we were
uh i forget which weekend it was but we
were there for like uh i was thinking
me uh my roommate and a bunch of girls
that we that were staying with us and
stuff we all went together
and how did you guys get invited to this
people just do it like i don't get
invited to orgies what do you mean i
don't know people just kind of do it who
got the invite you or someone oh not me
no i don't know one of the girls one of
the no no one of the dudes like that's
like in
he just like knew the people that had
the house
and and was there any requirements to
get in do they like check you i think
it's more like a word of mouth thing so
any any kind of
any kind of [ __ ] but it's like so far
you know what i mean you're not gonna
[ __ ] drive up to the handles for six
and a half hours to like attend a random
orgy in a house that you
uh you know that might not even be there
well apparently yes nico might because
he [ __ ] knows all about it but so you
pop you roll in there how many people
are in there
like 40 50 was a big-ass house and how
many people are having sex as you walk
in
i mean i live here like people were like
full-on [ __ ] so what was when you
walked in what was the situation it was
kind of chill people were just like
drinking
and then people like started getting in
the pool okay and it was weird because
like there are baskets
everywhere it's like a it's like a
[ __ ] mansion and there are baskets
everywhere with bathing suits
so people were just like changing it
yeah they were taking their clothes off
and changing the bathing suits to get in
the pool
why would they even be wearing bathing
suits
you know what i mean so was there naked
people there i saw some naked people
yeah they started like i we left before
it got to like the full-blown okay you
know the full-blown situation did you
see any sexual acts yeah what do you see
people getting naked
people you know people making out yeah
no one expressing one another second
third base
i don't know if i saw any oral
like i said we we went in
i didn't like it so i was like i'm good
and we left before how was the food did
they have hors d'oeuvres or i don't
remember this i was gonna ask how was
the buffet at the orgy
i don't know if there was any food
interesting oh this sounds like a low
quality orgy i think so
i think i think it was like kind of mid
yeah so so there are there was one like
i think there's like culti ones i think
there's one that i know
i don't know if i should out this person
but there's one that um
well there's a famous hbo comedian who
sucks
that attends uh there's like a sex party
that i know of i've never been to it but
i do it with everyone
yeah john oliver
no no no
i mean he is a furry though but bill
maher
i don't know i didn't say anything what
do you care about what bill maher thinks
i i i don't know that dude's okay so
bill
i'm with the [ __ ] uh lightning rod of
lawsuits brother i'm not trying to
oh i said it not no i mean john oliver
like you said
so but i've heard i when i think of
orgies especially for like celebs or
hand or beautiful people like you um
they have like a beauty like hey you got
to be hot to get in here yeah so that's
uh that's actually the process at the
sex party that i was talking about that
may or may not have uh
that that had uh you know attendees such
as um
names that rhyme with
shill father
um
chill father yeah she'll
far
and definitely not bill maher god got it
chill
anyway far shell far shofar yeah shofar
shafar
was it jewish orgy
no
no um so what happened why didn't you go
to bill maher's orgy no i was just not
i was i was back at that and i was uh
way back in the day i was hooking up
with a girl that had went to one that
had gone to one bro i'm sorry but if
it's a beauty standard orgy and i see
bill maher's tiny little [ __ ] old-ass
body there i'm not that's not true i
think like you either have to pay your
way in to get in in that situation or
you have to be like attractive
or a lot of a lot of people i believe
bring escorts with them
like a lot of rich guys will go there
and they'll bring like an escort
what the [ __ ] it's all okay wait bill
maher says i will not attend it orgy
there's guys in it he's lying bill maher
has a blow drop problem the hbo show
okay now i'm gonna pop off i know for a
fact he's lying i know he's been to
orgies he's that's crazy
there's guys in it
uh jimmy asked him if you would solve
world hunger would you fellate another
man
he said yes there you go
[Applause]
bill maher would suck a dick what a hero
for the world
what a guy all right we're so off the
[ __ ] so off the rails
we went all over the place and also
we're at 43 minutes so uh we got to do
an ad read all right we have one ad
thank you we're going to add a stamps
but first of all
here is what could have been if you
weren't such a baby
yeah
i can't i just like
i mean i would i would probably attend
one of those things just to see what the
[ __ ] is up but like
i don't know my consciousness can't
handle it i i think like some of those
things are probably uh very legal and
fine yeah but there is definitely a a
questionable line there of like you know
are there
are is there like an andrew tight uh the
webcam style situation happening here
like you never know you know what i mean
yeah do you have to wear uh protection
like was everyone wearing condoms and
[ __ ]
at the thing i went to no yeah no um but
i i don't know how it is for what is it
called like nixom or something that's
like one of them
there's a couple different ones uh
septum
sanctum sanctum was the one uh i know
that bill maher went to that's that has
a name yeah sanctum is did they have a
whale sanctum that is some [ __ ] eyes
wide shot do they have a website the
[ __ ] yeah sn ctm and the membership is
twelve thousand five hundred dollars to
fifty thousand dollars that's not bad
you have to apply the elite few who are
grant i mean there's a website here i'll
pull i pulled it up here you wanna see
wait there's a [ __ ] website
oh yeah you should have that in
the elite few who are granted access are
given the title of i can't even read it
from
my monitor is so [ __ ] far from my
face i can't even read it here send it
to me i could pull it
wait hold on hold on just google snctm
and it'll come up
instead of pulling mine up do you not
see um
do you not see hassan's monitor though
no no it is
yeah the elite few yeah let's zoom in
the
the elite few who are granted access
are given the title of novitiate or
approved non-member
as the newest participant in our
collective endeavor the attendee is
permitted to purchase tickets and vip
tables for any sanctum event worldwide
we encourage you to taste the fruits and
explore our boundaries
the novitiate will soon find there is
much more beyond the next door these
people are [ __ ] such losers this is
stupid this is the most exceptional
prequisites of what the [ __ ] i don't
know what was it
no
it's a typo um prerequisites of sanctum
come only with membership or level maybe
you're right maybe it's it so wait i
just pay up front on their [ __ ]
website the aurum level member is
entitled to a host of privileges not
extended to our non-member attendees
i just pay up front and then i can do it
yeah
this is dumb
it's it's uh the dominance membership is
reserved for the most discerning of
libertines with white glove treatment
sanctum can infuse the lifeblood of an
erotic awakening or meet the
unattainable expectations of the man or
woman who could have anything
only 20 dominus memberships are
permitted at any time if i'm paying
if i'm paying 50 000
what guarantee that you have you roll up
you're even gonna get
white glove white gloves which means
like they're gonna give you white gloves
at the sex party
just wear only white gloves
but all right let me let me think
speaking of which stamps.com yes
talking about white gloves you're going
to want to handle these stamps with
white gloves
because they're so valuable
yeah
on the other broadcast with what i did
we got in trouble like three times in
the livestream
making of white gloves right yeah you
want to wear like gloves because these
because you collect if you collect
stamps yeah a lot of people do you would
wear white gloves i got it it wasn't as
bad as some of the others we've got some
notes about your segways in the past
yeah why we're a little yeah but when
you make a whole big deal of it then
they go oh better watch it
let's talk about it for 30 seconds
well you started a dialogue
is it better we don't say anything
i just want to in this case yes i want
to know more about the buffet scene look
at these orgies they said fruit they did
say wait we're trying to move on from
that let me thank stamps
thank you to stamps.com for supporting
our show
if you're a small business owner you
know how important it is to be ready for
the insane holiday season and if you
haven't started prepping for the chaos
of mailing and shipping you're already
falling behind
you know the holiday has two ways of
sneaking up on us
it's time to prepare buddies
stamps.com has everything you need to
make your life a whole lot easier it's
24 7 post office that you can access
from anywhere a no-line no traffic no
hassle dan
talk to me
when i'm busy after a long day of being
at sanctum i like to come back and send
out packages
son i thought you were on my side here
[Laughter]
now you're getting it
dan your girlfriend uses uh stamp.com
yeah she does she runs a small business
from home uh she's an artist and she
does commissions and sells prints on her
website and stamps.com is the way that
she does all of her shipping and it is
amazing she doesn't have to do she
doesn't have to go to the post office
she does it all from home got a little
printer attached to her computer bada
bing bada boom weigh it on the scale get
your postage let me tell you how let me
tell you about this song because it's
incredible
they give you a scale
you put your packages together it's an
envelope a package whatever size or
scale it is you weigh it print the exact
postage because you got the scales
plugged in all that
and then you put it on your doorstep or
in the mailbox and they come pick it up
you don't it's it's unbelievable it's us
on it's unbelievable technology think
about it dude and here's the best part
you guys uh
you get major discounts with stamps that
you don't get
on your own check this out up to 86
off ups rates
and major discounts on usps are you
freaking kidding me right now
it's a stress fee a stress-free solution
for every small business use stamps.com
to print postage wherever you do
business
uh so you know
if you mail stuff man
this is it it's stamps.com or nothing
uh get ahead of the chaos and get
started at stamps.com today sign up with
the promo code leftovers for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus
free postage
and a free digital scale no long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page to enter the code
leftovers thank you thank you peace and
love to our good friend stamps.com
[Music]
all right we have made it zero way
through the document
uh thank you to i bought another orgy
for the fit to get
all right so
where the [ __ ] even are we uh um well we
can talk about we can talk about ben
shapiro well okay so how long have we
been going you know what's funny though
neither me nor dan
disavowed our best best friendship with
faze blanks here and we're we're we're
saying it sounds like you supporting him
it sounds like you almost want to vote
for rick cuz russo just i'm gonna be
honest with you like if it means
maintaining my friendship with faze
banks i'm doing it well listen i didn't
think this was the dunk i thought it was
uh well i i came in fully prepared with
a heavy heart to completely disavow
friendship with faze blanks but i gotta
say
proud of him for reaching out to you his
son you know he he he didn't just he's
buy in without thinking about it
critically so once again he is proven to
be a stand-up guy yeah well what he
asked
what did he he asked you what do you
think about this rick
yeah okay which by the way which by the
way i would like to still very much
attend one of those events faze banks if
that's brother banks let me know get in
his face rick caruso no no no no don't
there is a there's a delicate way to
handle these stuff in this [ __ ] face
bro no i'm not trying to do that at all
i'm trying to
sometimes it's good to be an impartial
observer don't bring a weapon
what no of course not i was just saying
also i would get [ __ ] owned
immediately what do you mean that guy
he's like a billionaire
yeah i would never do that yeah of
course the only weapons i got are these
and i'm not doing anything i can't get
rid of those yeah all right um all right
so phase bank w i guess uh ben shapiro
dropped the bomb tweet we can't live
heartbreaking the worst person you know
just made a great joke we were talking
about leonardo dicaprio's girlfriend
who's never uh exceed the age of 25 ben
shapiro uh
bless his tiny little soul
he couldn't stay with her because he had
to be present at the birth of his next
girlfriend
bad benny boy
wow not bad benny
we love it i hate i hate to i hate to
give him that dub but you know
it's funny i'm sure he i'm sure he went
back to being like haha like does she
identify as a helicopter you know that's
sort of the same one joke that they have
big old happy non-conforming transgender
uh birthing uh parent-to-parent day
um there's also another thing going on
here another l i guess but uh steven
crowder yeah talking about the trump
brain
i love this i love the story because
like
first of all i love the story because
like
it they like every conservative that's
come out and defended donald trump
uh because of trump's actions has has
looked like a [ __ ] giant idiot any
time the doj reveals more information
they have to go back move the goal post
and be like
uh actually well it's okay that he
didn't declassify it even if he did or
maybe he did to classify those documents
even if the fbi planted it you know what
i mean like every step of the way
president touches a document it
automatically declassifies yeah
even if he wasn't the president at the
time yeah even
because he's still the real president
which by the way trump did say which i
love i was making a joke about that and
it literally happened trump was like i'm
the real president this shows it we need
to do a new real we need to do a
re-election now
yeah uh the trump meltdown based on all
this stuff happening is incredible we're
getting to that i don't know how far
we're gonna make it at this rate let's
just watch this
stephen crowder is uh
equating posting youtube videos to
storming the beaches of normandy
he's got his mug a club mug of course
as he
as he gets ready to storm
the beaches of normandy
30 seconds
god be with you at least this is it 20
20.
you know what you said i heard you
saying i had the same thought his tom
hanks is weirdly good yeah i hate that
it's [ __ ] pretty kind of a dub for
steven crowder
it's and go deeper
i want regular content for all you it's
an election year so use those algorithms
you're not sure if your content is
borderline
of caution we don't need i mean it's
pretty good it's okay but why is it so
high he's talking like this just raising
his voice but it made me think of tom
hanks at least yeah yeah it's like it's
got the cadence but it's like an octave
too high like why is it so like maybe
maybe he just
listen get ready boys we're about to hit
the beaches i guess today we're
complimenting we're complimenting the
right but i think it's not bad i'm sorry
he said that he's at the bar so [ __ ]
low with his like every black person
impersonation is chris tucker's thing
you know it's just any time he does
anything else you're like well that's
all right it's not as bad you know into
the screen and the role of a lifetime
and this is like weirdly well produced
for something so embarrassing because
they're [ __ ] theater kids man this is
it
like if this dude kept his arthur job
which he did by the way for those of you
who don't know he was brain on arthur um
if he if he kept that job he wouldn't be
doing this [ __ ] he'd just be
like why is it that every [ __ ]
psychotic conservative reactionary
fascist uh has like a art school story
like i don't understand they're
ex-hollywood failures yeah they're all
ex-holy failures like ben shapiro steven
crowder or you know the most famous
reactionary of all time hitler oh was he
well he was an art failed artist that's
what i'm saying yeah yeah like
but if you even look at something about
artists
what's his name the breitbart guy uh
was like a failed hollywood andrew
breitbart bray bart
sorry steve bannon i was thinking of
well steve bannon yeah steve bannon was
goldman sachs guy but he he definitely i
mean he owns like i think he owns like
all the seinfeld ip i'm not mistaken
what what
steve bannon made his uh money in uh in
in pushing goldman sachs to
invest into uh power farmers in korea
and china like gold power farming
within the wow economy that's not that's
not fake that's real by the way straight
up all right we gotta we gotta we gotta
stay focused so we're never gonna get
through this phantom was a hollywood
producer though yeah
oh i don't know yeah he's not about that
yeah dude he produced 18 films he also
made a fortune off of seinfeld because
uh he he was the one who like sold off
the
um syndication deal yeah basically yeah
interesting of steve bannon a prominent
white uh nationalist anti-semite to
be a proponent of like what's been
called the most jewish show of all time
seinfeld yeah he was brought in to help
westinghouse electric negotiate a
minority stake acquisition in castle
rock entertainment the producer of the
iconic jerry seinfeld comedy right a
person familiar with the deal told the
rap crazy yeah yeah they're all failed
hollywood guys you're absolutely right
being bad
keep your content clean gentlemen
see you on youtube
this is so embarrassing i mean guys see
you on youtube
hosting is like war yes i feel like this
every
and oh this is the this is the thing
where like there's probably two violence
women can't do war you know what i mean
women can't do war like that's the main
point that they hammer in on this one
where like she gets shot in the head
multiple times throughout the [ __ ]
thing
um what was the point of this what were
they selling uh i think what they were
trying to say is posting is like the
real war oh he's not selling this is
just love for the game yeah wow what a
[ __ ] theater kid yeah talk about war
here's war here's what happens when war
comes to crowder yeah when he went out
when he when he pissed off the wrong
[ __ ] union guy
wonderful speaking of theater kids by
the way uh if you go back to tim poole
another prominent uh right wing rock
brained freak
he just put out a single did you guys
check if this was if we this got claimed
tim poole yeah we are in the clear okay
absolutely so tim oh yeah see he said it
he put out a song you guys are going to
[ __ ] love this by the way his band is
called tim cast
love that
which is rock and roll as [ __ ]
i mean that that's you know
it's oozing with creativity
yeah so here's tim poole darling up the
right uh
putting his
heart and soul out there for all you
guys
[Music]
oh [ __ ] and glorious 2160.
they find like white joji what the [ __ ]
is this
yeah i don't know who the [ __ ] this guy
is
yes
oh i know who that guy is he's the
ex-drummer of
uh the offspring he was uh he was the
replacement drummer for the oxford who
got kicked off the band because he
refused to get a coveted vaccine oh i
love that brilliant brave he's like
you'll find a home with me buddy yeah
the more the most divorced dad group you
could ever
they're so divorced they should be doing
butt rock i don't know why they did emo
[ __ ]
i feel like this falls in the category
of like guys who would most likely do
butt rock i feel like this isn't even
this is worse than emo this is like um
it's like 90s like alternative
run just there's even this one
like it's bad it's worse than everything
also tim poole
there's nothing rock and roll about tim
poole he is such a [ __ ] this guy sits
there and supports status quo he
supports the establishment all day that
is the antithesis of rock and roll this
man you're supposed to speak truth to
power this guy is like [ __ ] uh no you
don't understand rock and roll is about
respecting the cops yeah exactly and and
also making sure that our you know law
enforcement officers are properly
respected respect the blue yeah walk the
thin blue
yeah and also small business owners who
who here hasn't listened to the ballad
uh you know of of our wonderful real
troops which is the small business
owners absolutely
this is my ode to the chamber of
commerce
[Music]
i don't know why but this angle cracks
me up this man looks like a [ __ ]
gorilla he look at that angle
he uh yeah
dude you don't need the kovic shot ain't
gonna make you [ __ ] malformed you
already are dude he needs to be hit with
the evolution gun right
let's get you back in the womb bro we
need to we need to re-cookie we need if
he was one deviation away he'd be a
tadpole still with like the
arms and legs
grift core that's interesting somebody
in the chat shout out grifcore is the
are such genre [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't
hear a difference between his singing
voice and his speaking voice he's no
different he's just sissier he's like
i don't know what it's tim this is this
is embarrassing that's like
mark gormley
but people liked it that's what's kind
of the most shocking thing about this
well they're [ __ ] conservatives of
course they have no
they have no art so they have to like
latch on to anyone who's like yeah i'm
conservative and here this is the art
that i made that's why you brought the
[ __ ] offspring uh you know
second drummer like there's a reason
it's just team sports for them either
kid rock or tim yeah they [ __ ] andrew
breitbart is actually a perfect person
to mention uh you know rest in piss
andrew who died on a toilet bowl after a
cocaine bender if i'm not mistaken
um
but um what about
they're so they
like these guys
have so much resentment because culture
is still moved by like all the you know
gay art kids that they bullied in like
their [ __ ] backwater towns that moved
into hollywood and like made it
so there's still like a liberal slant in
the media which can be very conservative
across the board you know what i mean
um and that frustrates them
so they want to make an alternative
to counter it but the hard truth is they
[ __ ] suck but yeah they can't they
can't figure it out they got
nothing i love this status quo rock it's
so [ __ ] hard
why is he writing a love song
here i have a wake up i have an
alternative lyric for him it's not me
it's everybody else dude that would be
that would bop
you know just be honest bro don't don't
front like you [ __ ] have a love story
to tell feminism ruined his love life i
don't have kids yet my dad already had
two kids by now
it's not me no
it's everybody else you know what you
know what the problem is you're kind of
popping off yeah
i know i'm sorry who's that where did
that come from i'm starting a band it's
called uh
cast
it's called the h3 podcast yeah it's the
name of my band yeah
it's definitely not me
yeah
like they need to sample that i feel
like they need to do like i said butt
rock would work way better
[Applause]
[Music]
i feel like this is a psyop to make
people who listen to this want to
end it all
because that's what it or at least
that's what's happening to me currently
it's like evanescence mixed with like
daniel powder okay but it hasn't dropped
yet we're halfway to the song let's hear
the [ __ ] drop the intro is so long
well it's just that good bro we get it
you're wondering the house it's not even
a big house that's a tall dude though
or a very small house
oh my god this is literally a ballad to
a divorce dad
the court system is inherently flawed
women get all the rights and men get
[ __ ] on yeah it's like it's run by
feminazis
i have to pay [ __ ] alimony what is
this [ __ ]
okay
my wife my ex-wife says i can't see the
kids because i'm an alcoholic and maybe
i hit them a few times definitely not me
well definitely not tim because he
doesn't have that
big l big l for tim
he wishes he was divorced
i would love to be the engineer for this
song man recording him
it's a dream come true
[Music]
wait is there no drop is this it yeah
this is it no no no no no it happened
there's a hit there's there's gotta be
like a yeah no
it goes crazy in a second
you have to have that like
it's coming
there's only one thing i think like
creatively this is like the most obvious
[ __ ] rehash
dumb [ __ ]
oh but now she's gone
[Music]
wait she died because of the covet
vaccine
oh
this is a vaccine injury ballot is the
ballot this is the ballot to the the
pfizer moderna yo
yeah nailed it that's interesting my
kids all got autism and my wife died
yeah this is what the vaccine did to him
does anybody have a cure for autism
please email me at tim at timecast.com
you know that's his email by the way
i mean probably hey email's definitely
tim at timbercats.com
um
i don't know what it is the conservative
brain they're just not creative i don't
know what to say like
yeah their brain is made they got
nothing
it's like not
[Music]
art is always supposed to be boundary
pushing and uh
you know it has like a like a generic
degenerate disposition right because
it's like boundary breaking
so if your entire ideology revolves
around conserving and going back to
traditional foods there's that you're
gonna have a hard time inherently
breaking them all interesting art yeah
bruh he got this offspring drummer
there's no drums in this
that's it's all [ __ ] uh
played your strengths bro yeah like [ __ ]
that's interesting that's funny when is
the drop if there's no drama i swear
it's coming anywhere 90 there it is
there
there it is they went there bro the
song's almost over
oh you see the
the black lines on the wall that's
that's the that's the vaccine coursing
through revenge the poison no
it's not me
it's everybody else
it's like they kick me out they kick me
out of the restaurant of dreams
they kicked me out
oh i forgot i got the side yeah i forgot
about that they kicked me out they got
me assad why'd you get kicked out of
that restaurant again
um
he didn't have a reservation he didn't
even get kicked out he just he claimed
he claimed he had as a reservation and
that they were still making him wait 15
minutes for a table and that's that's
rock and roll yes
yeah
by the way it's not covet it's just a
divorce dad thing we're learning here
yeah which is more fun in my opinion
yeah
absolutely you want it you want to
freestyle more or son no
the most
[Music]
everyone should own a nuke oh my god
he's such a kyle dude he's breaking the
drywall
dude
breaking the fourth wall of drywall
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no she got in an accident no they got
divorced and then she got in a car
accident
[Music]
no
wow
look like that bad of an accident to be
honest
it didn't yeah it didn't look that bad
it just exchanged insurance and
maybe she's fine i don't know one of the
chat said panic at the capitol
january 6 is a national holiday it was
really antifa that was there breaking
stuff
tim castle records what a [ __ ] love
records the band's tim cast the podcast
tim captain
and and he's very creative he's a very
creative individual yes
i mean copy pasting like the exact
vibes and music of like
a band that was
probably like the 25th most successful
evanescence cover band is the way to go
in 2022 i think yeah here's the tweet
we're talking about by the way i went to
a diner with my girlfriend
and it was told it was a 20-minute wait
after only a few minutes a couple walked
in it was seated right away
i complained and left right away
i don't tolerate [ __ ] and i don't
tolerate people who think i should care
when they do
it's not my fault it's everybody else
donald trump is a national hero 50 say
sweep is actually what happened
such a rock and roll [ __ ] tweet
yeah i don't take [ __ ] from nobody
especially hostesses at olive garden
yeah
i also don't believe this because he
says he has a girlfriend yeah
liar yeah all right so that was fun we
were having too much fun here today my
girlfriend is real she goes to a
different school
she's from canada too
she's super hot check out this picture
but don't google image reverse search it
oh i gotta pee so i have to pee as well
but you go first [ __ ] you go first we
have two bathrooms let's both go and
then dan can just chat for a minute yeah
okay maybe that's the best way let's
both go we have two bathrooms
that's right
it's a little bit of a humble brag ethan
can we get a pole going we got two
bathrooms make it clear
that we're not crossing streams not
there's anything wrong with it but i
don't need the speculation right i hear
you we have gloves from yesterday can we
get a pole going to see who's going to
piss faster ethan or hassan take your
bets now people
who's the faster pier the faster pier
by the way hassan ethan they're lying we
only have one bathroom right now one's
out of order so
excuse me no [ __ ] they're definitely
crossing streams
[Music]
i see you're doing a shtick and i ruined
it by saying what it's okay
what's going on with the we're like
zooming around the set right now i'm not
taking a pause this is sick
oh yeah yes yes
how bad do you have to pee right now
uh hassan is winning the poll by 88
percent
to 12 wow
he got a head start so it makes sense
yeah he did get a head start yeah so not
it's not the most scientific experiment
that we're running here i have to pee so
bad people might be thinking that
ethan's thinking a grumpy as well he's
been known to
take these mid-show grumpies pinch off a
loaf
uh by the way shout out to everybody in
the chat that was hitting me with some
fantastic uh tim poole fake band names
there was one that i saw that cracked me
up it was uh 30 seconds to gars
so good job all of it
look at that and our
some random chatter in our chat is ten
times more creative than tim pool i'm
surprised
absolutely
absolutely
uh what else is going on what's going on
with all you
here in the office how's everybody doing
good doing doing pretty good horrible
what's wrong cam nothing i just talked
to everyone else was going one way i
wanted to go the other way i want to be
unique
you always put a smile on my face every
morning and you do too zach it's a
two-way smile street
i came in this morning
and only zach was here and he had set up
a whole leftover okay by himself zach is
a legend in my defense i'm sharing a
bathroom with three women right now in
my small apartment this was it why are
you i won't take it nobody was
criticizing you no i'm just saying me
and me and zach usually set it up so
just yeah well i'm just i helped too i'm
trying to shout out my boy zach over
here i don't know i should and you're
over here trying to make it all about
a.b
next week i'm not going to do anything
zach
why don't you give me a just like this
week or give me a plug a b and we'll
it'll be fine zach your show is going to
sell don't worry you're good buddy give
him give me a plug and what we'll cover
plug what just you know zach lewis live
at the uh trip marine but like where
like just i'm just hanging out who wins
who's gonna get to the set first here
oh both his participants
i just want to point out that i i was
faster than anything at pisces you got
to the bathroom way before me dude it's
more also is peeing faster like is that
like dope or something i don't get it i
don't know
taking a paw because when did ping fast
become admirable i guess maybe you don't
want to waste any time in there right
just a mini game it's more efficient
right like you save time in life one of
life's mini games that's a good way of
putting so did you all cross the streams
or no
yeah i i started peeing and then ethan
knocked on the door i opened the door
i'm still peeing at this point
and then he was like i'm gonna pee
between your legs nice i said you need
me to hold it for you yeah i said then i
was like all right you know what and i
stopped myself i sat down so he peed
between my legs little neat little
sneak-o action going on
man you remember how sneako's girlfriend
got bukkakeed and it broke him that's
sad
yeah i heard i heard something probably
sucks that people mention that
people don't actually mention because i
don't think a lot of people know huh
will do it to admit anything jerking off
his dog
what why is nobody talking about what
wait hold on i gotta play this for you i
gotta play it somebody sent me that link
it's the best
best wait is that why he got banned off
youtube no that was for gambling he went
on he went on bradley martin's podcast
and he starts talking about how he jerks
off his dog i'll show it to you right
now i swear to god it's the craziest
thing
he milks his dog yeah literally hold on
bro that's you can't recover from that
well nobody's talking about it and i
don't get why well now and now you got
me talking about it okay steve will do
it and the will do it is jerking off
your dog
we dubbed him i think it was zach's
steve will jerk it steve will yank it
yeah all right let's not interrupt i
just want you to watch this whole thing
it's about a minute long bradley riley
martin is such a gorilla okay sorry yeah
he is yeah he
he's got a lot of thigh action here we
commented
we're trying to woo bradley to not hate
us as much so i think
that we might have [ __ ] it up i got it
in there i'm homies with a bunch of his
homies okay okay okay that's a good word
guys
uh hassan's raw reaction to steven let
him juice you up ready years because
we're so tight you're together no matter
what i mean you weren't breaking up if
you were broken up you would not be
together yeah that's what i did dude i
did that for years man
yeah for so many years honestly i miss
my ex girl from the dogs there's no
reason for that much style bro look at
that [ __ ] dude
i respect it i respect that
he's [ __ ] dude he's doing reverse
split squats on the regular okay okay
all right and he wants you to know it
all right i don't want to get
distracted bradley martin shaves his
legs i think
he's competing
is that why he's looking pretty smooth
this might be or does he just do it like
he got some razor burn here too
no that's from dead lifting
all right okay no we guys we got to stay
focused we've got way too much to talk
about
i missed i swear i really missed that's
dude that's the thing oh dude when we
broke up we broke up for eight months
right how i started telling her i
started messaging donald on instagram i
really miss her dogs man
yeah dogs are dope selena um our dog
start is like is he's
recently he's been like you come home
and they're just come everywhere what
are you talking about i come over the
couches but you see it you see the [ __ ]
yeah usually comes stains and his dick
is like all big and throbbing so like it
sucks but like
this is like kind of crazy i'm saying
this but one
i'm the cool dad now okay
i'm the favorite you're the favorite of
the coolest and two
you can control where the [ __ ] goes
what are you talking about
so i get ivs all the time yeah yeah i
know you know they wear gloves yes so
lately i've been just like groceries ago
you put on the glove and you said donald
he's going on his stomach or like kind
of something right here or like you go
cow style cow stuff styles what are you
talking about
and then you go and usually just play
like uh like uh like i like cartoon like
disney like family friendly and [ __ ] uh
and he's
has been uh i've been like jerking off
donnie jerking your dog off
bro this is like mathematically the
worst way you could have described this
anyway like why did you add the disney
cartoon
like he just made it
like it's already so weird it's worse
but he was like i want to make this
mathematically the worst thing i could
say
we talked about this for like an hour
yesterday so bro this [ __ ] is what the
[ __ ] dude let's let it roll
this is it gets it gets more dawson is
rolling in his grave right now shane
dawson is like i got canceled for what
[ __ ] figured his dog does this
guy get away with it dude what the [ __ ]
i did not come on my dog jordan however
jordan yeah did not come on it
has been uh ivan was like jerking off
donnie jerking your dog i went back
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on so
you're telling me right now that you've
been jerking your dog off and now so he
doesn't cool dad no
it might sound crazy but it's strictly
business um okay
this is where and kind of i watch
something occupy myself and it's more of
just a
it's more of a
little workout but the thing is bro he
said i'm the favorite dad now because i
jerk my son off
oh my god dude what the [ __ ] i know he
said he said he like he's bribing his
his uh girlfriend's dog with with [ __ ] i
know it with the with the orgasmic
experience yo
i know
bro to too much
this dude's got alec baldwin face from
drinking way too much alcohol way too
early bro i swear to god this is what
happens it's interesting he mentions he
gets ivs which i'm assuming is for
hangovers it's like well but let's keep
going because it's
not gonna help you brother dad because
imagine if you couldn't jerk off and i
was like what the [ __ ] i do he comes by
like [ __ ] a pillow let him [ __ ] the
pillow that's his normal move dude yeah
but imagine imagine you trying to come
by like [ __ ] a pill let him [ __ ] the
pillow brother hard yeah it's probably
not the best but then imagine you had
someone to come in and go help bro he's
a zoo fight honestly that's [ __ ]
that's dope you bro
no it's not bradley what the [ __ ] are
you saying bradley's like yo that's kind
of dope bro you love your dog bro what
the [ __ ] i'm just gonna let it ride i'm
gonna let it ride cause we talked to us
for an hour yesterday i just want your i
just want yours what you can't just like
portraying the control where they come
goes okay and i feel like he likes me
better than he likes me way better than
selena now because i'm the cool dad dude
i'll be honest i didn't see this
conversation going that way but that's
crazy i kind of respect it i mean dude
if you couldn't jerk off i'm trying to
find myself in that position and it's
like donnie can't go to the rub and tug
no yeah he can't there's no dog hookers
damn bro
it's like bro you just got your mom and
dad mom's not cool you don't have a girl
you don't have girl dogs to [ __ ] no
girls but french let him [ __ ] the pillow
brother what the [ __ ] yeah i don't know
anything about facebook or meta is this
is this misinformation it could be i
don't know this could actually be
misinformation oh i love that they think
they can't talk about how you get more
of them i know but frenchies apparently
can't i don't know so how the how do
they get maybe they made my favorite
parts coming up i don't know they i
don't know i think they
pretty sure same thing ivs
the nurses were oh introvert oh you take
it they put the baby into the dog for
example when i jerk off donnie if i i'm
wearing the glove already so what i do
is you just uh finger scoop the [ __ ] like
like uh like his dipping sauce
and then you just [ __ ] you just put
it in uh well bro you're right you did
you did how the [ __ ] did he finger dips
to come out like that's not in vitro
fertilization no i know i know there's
no
i worked at a ranch
i never jerked off a horse but i did uh
i was there i had to carry the [ __ ]
like literal
leather condom it is a real process
though they do they do have a similar
steve will do it style process of like
getting a stallion but that's that's not
right
that you have all the [ __ ] you get a
stallion you put a bunch of mares like
uh in here
uh on on on like a lineup basically you
get the stallion horny as [ __ ] kind of
like nico's girlfriend in a way but
pretty much yes and then
and then the stallion comes in there's a
rack
uh where you would normally put all the
saddles on too when you're working on
the saddles
basically the stallion comes in and
[ __ ] starts humping the rack
and you put a leather condom over it
like you you put a [ __ ] massive like
this big leather condom over the horse's
[ __ ] and then he comes into it
j-r-a that's interesting that's for
breeding
what's he does he says it's just because
he he wants he just he feels bad that he
can only help a pillow he wants to jerk
him off and help him out in that way
that's really that that is extra weird
that is so weird and i say this to
someone like i said who has had to carry
a [ __ ] leather condom full of horse
[ __ ] uh when i worked at a [ __ ] ranch
you wanna smell it
no
no dude i was like
steve would take a little [ __ ] taste
probably did you know this i have a
frenchie what the [ __ ] this is weird as
[ __ ] but i think you just put your
finger inside them you so you get to
come and you stick it in them that's how
they do it or uh because they would die
these are some freaky ass dogs or a
squeezer you squeeze it inside them
the thing is like they are genetically
deformed kind of like stable doing
not dissimilar to steve
but from from centuries of inbreeding
specifically so that they could have
those genetic deformities and because of
that like they can't [ __ ] because they
they die if they [ __ ]
can you could drinking too much alcohol
modify your dna
i don't know if i can steve is trying he
will do it if it does steve will jerk it
ladies and gentlemen god damn that's
crazy
dude what the [ __ ] yeah i know
it's totally nuts because like when uh
joe biden said he fingers his cat
everybody was like yo you got to see
this but nobody's talking about steve
will do it that's just
like no there's like uh what is it anal
prolapse or whatever when your dog has
like a like a leaky butthole you have to
squeeze it out oh yeah that's like a
medical thing that you have to do for
your dog jerking off your dog on the
other hand is like you're not fingering
its butthole either it's like a thing i
take it to the vet to do that yeah oh
it's called uh
it's called uh the expressing
the anal glands yeah when they get like
too inflamed they're just like [ __ ]
dropping goo everywhere it's nasty as
[ __ ] oh this is interesting excessive
alcohol consumption can cause irrep
irreversible changes to the dna
uh so maybe he developed congratulations
when i took off donnie
steve will do it steve will do it is uh
is uh
going backwards in the evolutionary you
got banned off youtube for gambling
that's crazy that youtube has a better
[ __ ] tos than than twitch yeah you
can't do that [ __ ] on youtube you
haven't ever been able to we should say
we that's what we think it hasn't been
confirmed it's definitely what happened
because he gidion caught a [ __ ] fake
strike when he wasn't even promoting
gambling big l
virginian
lan anyway so there's that there was
another detour but an important one
here's rob schneider the biggest hack in
the world
uh on glenn beck
talking about how he's ready to give up
at all
uh uh uh for the cause and i don't know
what it all is uh that he has
but let's find out empire of dirt real
rob baby
for what you believe and i would gladly
never be cast again
as the
carrot as the humanoid carrot in this
adam sandler film
yeah absolutely yeah because because if
we don't have that let's go back nothing
dude rob schneider is such a [ __ ]
hack dude he's such a he's a stapler
yeah exactly are you willing to lose it
all for what you believe
absolutely yeah cause i if because if we
don't have it then we have nothing what
kind of weird like grandstanding is what
do you what are you wrist rob schneider
in his most pivotal role yet a
reactionary washed up hollywood actor
yes that's right folks only here in rob
schneider's world can you find another
washed up has been turning to magga for
relevancy by the way he's like the beat
at this rate he's like the most be
[ __ ] actor nobody cares about and he
has a resurging a career being a a
right-wing hack it's like they they'll
take anyone they can get does he though
i don't even think he's a resurgence of
a career really no he's going on if
you're if the resurgence is happening
because you went on the glenn beck
podcast like you it's over you're not
researching anything dude he's gonna get
cast in the next uh january 6 movie i'm
sure of it
uh breitbart's january 6 movie he's
going to be a lead role
rob schneiderlin is the fbi agent that
told you to take the gun
rob schneider plays
the car
i'm the leader of the bravo anymore i
care about my children's me the country
that they're going to live in and my
hope is this my hope is a beautiful
story from a from a um
from a chaplain
in england a lot of it's got a lot of
views though from when the american flag
came over in the early days
of world war ii when the american flyers
came over after this is like the dog
days 1942 late 42 when like
their friends were getting blown out of
the sky
they would go over on the bombers and
half would come back two-thirds would
come back you know but they were dying
and there was one just like really awful
uh
week
two weeks where there was a very high
percentage of these pilots were getting
blown out of the sky and getting killed
that's like us and social media
they went to the um
prison they went to the to the uh to the
air force chapel and they the pilot said
why
i said our friends are dying why should
we do this why should we get up tomorrow
and fly they do this at like literally 4
45 it's supposed to leave 5 30.
why should we do this tell us why um
they didn't say they weren't going to do
it so tell us why we should do this our
friends are dying tell us
and the chaplain was really you know
woke up and said um well
humanity has come out of it
has come out of the dark ages
we've come out of where people
get burned at the stake people
believe and and go along with this and
there's a darkness that we have come out
of and doing a more of an enlightened
period a more freer period and anyway
[ __ ] trans people bro these
[ __ ] need howard zinn in their
lives so bad by the way rest in peace uh
like a people's history is a really good
book i highly recommend um even the
example that he's using he lived it
right um he actually was a bomber pilot
uh during world war ii and those were
such formative experiences for him
bombing civilian territory where germans
were living in and even using napalm in
certain instances was such a traumatic
experience for him as an american
uh bomber pilot uh within the air force
that uh he it totally like broke his
brain he was like this is completely
unacceptable and i saw
i i saw the horrific actions that we
committed
um that it it legitimately uh it
legitimately changed his mind he's a
brilliant guy uh awful
awful things that uh america has done
he's always been like the foremost
anti-imperialist voice on uh protesting
anyway so
uh on that front he's he's even wrong on
that front but also
it's ridiculous to to compare that
okay to compare fighting nazis right to
what like uh posting on twitter
harassing the nurses at the boston
children's hospital like what the [ __ ]
you think that's the same like you are
the nazi in that situation man what the
[ __ ] wrong with you you don't
understand like you think nazis were pro
trans no they were literally
anti-trainers first book born first book
burnings happened
uh for a boatload of medical data that
revolved around uh trans people like
that was the first ever public nazi book
burning that ever occurred it was a
bunch of uh medical research on trans
people
so you know they were just like you man
don't worry
and he said this
is a step back into those darkness these
are the darkest parts
of humanity
and we need to stand up for that now
and that requires this
require you maybe i'm no sacrifice i'm
thinking this is rob schneider talking
about jerking off his dog
he's like we have to do this it's a
sacrifice that we must do i will do it i
will
live in a world where my dog
i deuce bigelow male gigolo will jerk my
dog off to completion when i jerk off
donny
and just like
the allies flew over nazi germany
my dog requires
the man the dog he can't jerk off by
himself
so i scooped to come out
like like the americans scooped the
nazis out of germany
and just like they tasted victory i
tasted the [ __ ] oh god
oh you gotta go there
god damn rob schneider ladies and
gentlemen american hero
thank you rob schneider
all right dude let's get to the trump
part because we are so [ __ ] bad on
time yeah
so new revelations uh they've been lying
their ass off this whole time trump and
everyone trying to run defense for him
the fbi how did this photo come out was
this
fbi uh released it
so they're like yo uh these documents
that you say weren't here bro look at
this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ] top secret
uh
sci
top secret top secret top secret this
[ __ ] is chilling
like this is the new ship
you know how we used to collect
goosebumps
that's how he collects top secret
government documents yeah he's just like
he just took him
the best part about it is that this is
the stuff that he did not give back so
uh of course now we know
that this has been an ongoing
investigation um they asked nicely
multiple times they thought that the
trump camp was actually uh you know
uh completely uh meeting their demands
they realized maybe there's some more
top secret sci like top top top secret
clearance
uh documents that were not actually
recovered from that original extraction
so they uh working with uh some insider
uh people within within mar-a-lago or
within trump's camp which we do not know
who because they were trying to figure
out uh who it was from the affidavit but
they weren't able to
um
decided to get a search warrant and
execute that search warrant
and these are the results this is the
material that they produced
um
any of these documents in any other
normal person's house you're [ __ ]
you're going to jail yeah yeah yeah um
absolutely as a matter of fact
people that
people that have actually leaked top
secret documents or classified documents
even if they were redacted even if they
work with journalists have gone to uh
have gone to prison and and some of
those people were heroes as a matter of
fact chelsea manning is a good example
of this mm-hmm i think adventures
snowden is a hero as well
um
he is in exile in russia
uh i even think julian assange did a did
a very played a very important role you
might not like him personally he might
not agree with his politics but
ultimately he did the right thing um
regardless of his biases against uh the
democratic party or hillary clinton i
don't give a [ __ ]
but this isn't for that reason
as a matter of fact we don't know what
the reason is because it's so laughably
so comically stupid there's no like
there's no [ __ ] explainable reason
for this like the only reason to steal
this much top secret documents is
is malicious i mean there's no [ __ ]
other explanation i mean he just took
him he just took him and then when the
fbi was like hey we know you took these
when nara said hey we know you took
these
give it back he was like okay
and then he kept the couple and refused
to give everything back
at that point you've been got you know
what i mean you've been had what the
[ __ ] are you doing i mean one one uh
uh guess at it is that
or it's been said that some of these
documents have the names of uh
informants and and other
no that was the that was the original
hsc or hcs uh classification documents
that was originally recovered in the
first uh in the in the first batch the
fact that he took those issues
the name of of informants and hostile
government powers like the only reason i
have that is to [ __ ] extort
blackmail use as a bargaining chip
um it's it's utterly insane it's
[ __ ] nuts
guys
i also read these documents some of them
were so top secret that even the fbi
agents there yeah had to get special uh
yeah they have their special parents to
even look through them yeah exactly
that's like
no that totally makes sense the
president has access to that obviously
because he's a [ __ ] president he has
the highest level of security clearance
but even then he he uh can't just like
run around with this [ __ ] there is a
i don't know there is a there's a clear
protocol for handling this kind of [ __ ]
uh handling this kind of information and
it's pretty funny to see uh the right
wingers try to defend donald trump uh
when they're taking l after l after l
ultimately this is not the worst thing
that he's ever done but it's absolutely
such a clear-cut uh like
easy to understand violation of the law
we don't know what's in those documents
to say it's not the worst thing he's
ever done
no i mean i'm just saying that he's done
a lot of horrible [ __ ] yeah i mean
throughout his presence there's so much
but the really interest and by the way
it's like they made such a fuss over
hillary clinton handling of the email
the email server classified yeah
information oh he changed the look he
changed the law he made that look he
made it a felony it was a misdemeanor
originally and he turned it into a
[ __ ] felony and now he's getting
caught up in it
in his own law change what trump's been
saying all of his supporters were like
oh it's a planted the fbi planted it
well he's basically come out and admit
that they that they didn't plant it and
it is there i mean here he's been
popping off on truth social
there seems to be confusion as to the
picture where documents were sloppily
thrown on the floor
and then released photographically
for the world to see as if that's what
the fbi found when they broke into my
home wrong
they took them out of a carton and
spread them around the carpet making it
look like a big fine for them they
dropped them not me very deceiving and
remember we could have no representative
including lawyers present during the
raid they were told to wait outside
is he saying they went in there with a
car with a yes
so he's still trying to go along with it
they planted it narrative
which is hilarious because like
you know he also said i declassified all
of them
so like what did you declassify the
planted ones ahead of time too you knew
that the fbi was going to plant them
it's just all over the place it's all
over the [ __ ] place yeah this is the
uncropped photo of uh trump's uh office
yes so you can see here
classified documents he's actually he's
actually a bit of a hoarder
you'll notice wait is this real yeah 100
real oh my god
no it's not real it's just like oh jesus
[ __ ] dude you got you you got you got
you've got cam
excuse me excuse me fake news
excuse me uh okay so here trump's lawyer
goes on fox news and further
incriminates him he really hires only
the best lawyers in the world and i
gotta he goes he goes for tv lawyers and
that's why he keeps getting owned he has
tom fitton who has an english degree and
then these two uh he has two lady
lawyers that he hired one from oan
directly this one is the new one the
other one that was president mar-a-lago
literally just an oan tv lawyer
i don't think any the problem is the
same with andrew tape
there no good lawyer
with any reputation is going to work
with them that's not true lawyers are
[ __ ] demons man
dude come on they would they would it's
just the reason is the reason why they
don't want to work with donald trump is
i'm pretty sure he doesn't want to pay
i think he's just very bad like he's
notorious for
signing people on and like never paying
contractors and being like the shittiest
[ __ ] boss basically yeah i've heard
that so i think like he's gone through
so many lawyers that way but like
lawyers are [ __ ] awful dude i mean
look at alan i know that's true and
there's people like alan dershowitz and
rudy well rudy g only
rudy giuliani barely qualifies but
big reputable law firms i really don't
think they take this case they don't
want history they don't want that heat
they have a ton of clients they don't
want to piss you it's very polarized
i can see that but i'm just saying like
at least he could do is get a shark you
know what i mean get a [ __ ] ambulance
chaser get pnp man [ __ ] the guy who gets
people off on like you know triple
homicide yeah the tick tock guy yeah
yeah yeah
[ __ ] it just like you know play around
with it
all right here we go
yeah nowhere what what's happened is now
they've put this picture out so that you
would assume and i am somebody who has
been and the press loves to talk about
this especially today i'm somebody that
has been in his office i've seen it this
is not the way his office looks they
give you this appearance that you walk
in and there's these top secret
documents just strong she's so [ __ ]
dumb wait wait that's not the point yeah
okay
you are so dumb they're like wow i can't
believe they spread the documents like
yeah they're taking a [ __ ] photo of
all the things that they've recovered
yeah um one of my favorite counters to
this was oh if it was so top secret why
are you showing the documents i mean
that's a matter of national security
it's like not showing yeah in it wait
first of all they're doing it because
you want to [ __ ] release it you
demanded that they show their hand so
you can't [ __ ] complain about it when
they when they comply with your you're
they're not showing anything they're
just they don't even show anything but
i'm just saying like they keep asking
for more information whether it be the
search warrant which they had access to
and refused to reveal for some weird
reason they talk about the affidavit
unsealing the affidavit while
simultaneously trying to block the fbi
from looking at what the classified
information is by
invoking trying to invoke executive
privilege right because trump's camp is
on the one hand saying release the
affidavit release the [ __ ] search
warrant right on the other hand they're
secretly behind the scenes trying to
stop the fbi from even looking at what's
in the classified documents is like what
the [ __ ] are you doing and
and they're they're basically tackling
every avenue they can this is a classic
trump
move and and it has been very successful
because it's not about the truth it's
not about finding out what is actually
going on it's about uh whatever
narrative sticks to your sycophantic
psychotic base of support so that you
can you know move the
move public motivation towards uh
defending you and find something to
to you know attack the uh attack a
common enemy
her saying they like just laid out the
documents like that it's like you know
when they do a big drug bust and put all
the drugs and guns and [ __ ] on the table
and take a picture of it that's like the
drug deal being like yo they clearly
just put them on the table what do you
think we just walk in there and it's all
on the table yeah it's planted
about a b they don't understand
something could be marked top secret
could be marked classified the
presidential records act he would have
said this is declassified it doesn't get
a new marking all the time if he did if
they were planted why do you even care
about that
he left the office it is a complete
public spectacle and i'm not really
going to stand by it anymore you know i
personally what are you going to do
about it
and intimidated people have tried to
intimidate it's not going to work you
can't just put a picture like this and
say look
did did the fbi do that or was that the
way that room looked before they went in
there that's awesome what are you guys
even discussing yeah
that's so funny like yeah yeah one of
the one the one behind 2a if you look at
the photos there's one mark 2a that one
is so clearly like turned over
you know what i mean like that's not how
they found it man and was this two-way
card there when you walked in yeah was
there was there a there's a ruler i can
see that there's a ruler
was that on the floor it's like
what is this conversation
any first-hand novel yeah i'm sure
you've seen the press when the fbi came
in
when the fbi came in were were the top
secret documents censored with whiteout
i mean that seems weird that is odd
that's not how top secret documents
would look like i don't think it's like
dude you know you understand this is a
plant
as you know i have been down there i'm
down there frequently i have never seen
that i have never ever seen that that is
not the way his office looks anybody i i
just can't get over the fact that
they're actually
debating that's what happens when you
have nothing you have nothing else so
yeah
i mean i kind of understand it i
understand why they are desperately
looking for like any any other avenue to
to change the narrative away because
every single step of the way
from start to finish they kept saying
oh well maybe they planted the documents
okay well even if they didn't plant the
documents i declassified the documents
actually i complied with the authorities
why didn't they ask nicely oh they did
ask nicely and we actually hid
additional documents
that i did return but these ones were
planted so so that's the problem is that
like uh they don't have a lot of uh
leeway because they are not looking for
a consistent uh defense because their
actions are they're just trying to offer
you technically indefensible
this is the best part coming up here
anybody that knows president trump's
office he has guests frequently there it
is
it's just a joke they literally yeah
that's the problem dumbass
that's why the fbi was worried
about having top secret sensitive
documents in an office where there's
people coming in and out of there all
the time yeah stump [ __ ] really how are
you gonna complain about hillary
clinton's unsecured server and then
support this this uh clown show
and taken out documents they wanted or
cover letters as it is and put it about
so that the public believes that this is
top secret documents that were on his
floor
it's ridiculous i can tell you
personally it's ridiculous you're not
that dumb stop it
you know they they're not but they
understand the audiences right
but even then i don't know i don't know
i don't know if this is gonna motivate
uh enough of the republican base to be
like yeah you're right actually there is
a lot of like i think the only people
that will get motivated from this are
like q anon uh adjacent folks like the
the hyper radicalized people
right
um which will then
further
cause a rift that we are now seeing
inside of the republican party with like
the mitch mcconnells trying to distance
themselves from donald trump because
uh donald trump and his uh
uh his brand is
not necessarily helping them win general
elections like you have to be on board
with donald trump to win the primary but
you cannot if you cannot win the general
election against a democrat with like a
trump adjacent candidate
then you're [ __ ] then the republican
party is now in this weird situation
because trump is now a demon that could
always third party that could always uh
pull votes away
from from the republicans
and therefore has this extreme amount of
power and influence so
they're they're in a really unique
position here because they're [ __ ] and
they're extended their hand with the
with the roe v wade decision and now on
top of that they're uh you know they're
they're in a double bind where they have
really bad candidates in the senate
i think all this sarah haley just lost
the last
she got dominated yeah sarah palin
which oh my god i'm just so happy she
got [ __ ] owned on that
and lost by 10 points so i think all
this [ __ ] it keeps chipping away at
trump i think people are tired even his
supporters are tired of all this [ __ ]
and ultimately
i think i don't think he's got a shot
but it's gonna be a hell of a show
anyway here's pnp if trump would have
just hired a real attorney stealing top
secret government documents public and
decency zero jail time so
let's go
did it again folks public indecency he
did it again
yeah he whipped it out about that one
yeah he whipped it out
he jerked off the door
is there
is there an album and they're getting
owned on the loan relief too because
that's like a big that's a big like
positive there's a big dove for the
democrats as well right um so it's all
on the democratic party not to [ __ ] this
up at this point uh it doesn't seem like
merrick garland is gonna release
anything
until after the elections which is silly
in my opinion but we'll see what what
comes of that
that offers uh more
time for the republicans to build like a
consistent narrative about how like this
is purely political this is totally
unacceptable you know
so
yeah trump's been under so much heat he
really tweeted this out and
my heart goes out to him donald trump uh
uh uh on true social says why are people
so mean and i love that that really hit
me hit me you know
i i feel that mr president
why are people so damn only 7 000
truths
and 1 700 wreath truths yeah must have
just dropped yeah
i mean true social it just got dropped
from oh no he's gonna be the next tim
cass dude is that what's under the maga
hat yeah
everybody's so mean nobody's like
mean to me
if i was gone nobody would even [ __ ]
care man he's like he goes he's like
rosie o'donnell's a [ __ ] cow pig ass
fat [ __ ] loser i hate her guts i hope
she dies why are people so mean yeah
like the biggest [ __ ] dick
like he's the biggest dick in the world
and that's fine people love that about
him but why how are you gonna complain
that people are so mean no i love that i
love that i mean that's that's trump
though because he's a sassy [ __ ] at the
end of the day you know what i mean
sassy he's always been a sassy [ __ ]
like his his meanie bobini attitude is
actually just sass
but when people are mean to him that's
like oh dude you got the guy that's
what's under the mega hat
yo when did he get plugs yo that's
awesome mgt
oh is that an mpt yeah
machine gun trump
yeah he'd be unstoppable yeah every
scene kid would vote for him they would
come out and vote for the first time
yeah
uh
yeah also i don't know if you heard
about this
that's not the only trouble trump is in
uh in georgia things are heating up
quite a bit a special grand jury under
the direction of fulton county d.a
fannie willis is exploring whether
donald trump and his allies violated
georgia state law in their efforts to
reverse
the uh president losing the state in
2020 trump's effort included his
notorious phone call with georgia's
secretary of state where he asked him to
fine 11 000 votes
a grand jury has subpoenaed testimony
from rudy giuliani lindsey graham the
investigation is not bound by doj policy
about being cautious in pursuing
investigations advan in advance of
elections
and it seems to me
and from what i've heard is that in
georgia he could be facing his
most dangerous
uh prosecution yet i mean i don't like
fanny villas willis i'm gonna be honest
with you the georgia d.a uh is
definitely a careerist
she is absolutely looking to make a name
for herself this is a good thing this is
a correct application of rico i think in
this circumstance oh yeah he's being
he's being investigated for racketeering
but but she is uh she loves the rico
charges and used it against slime free
slime free young thug free gunna okay
uh i yeah she she uses she uses uh rap
lyrics uh to to put together a patchwork
investigation for a ricoh charge that's
already like
you know uh purposely vague and
difficult to i mean very easy to pin
people with
um so i'm not i'm not her biggest fan
but you know more power to her she
should focus on this instead of it seems
like she is jailing uh more
rappers who who
literally made it out the hood like
well it seems like she has quite a case
going i just want to find
uh
11
780
[Music]
votes which is one more that we have not
that because we want to say i own
yeah so i mean in georgia law they have
kind of
state laws against uh hampering uh
meddling in the election and
it's very interesting to read about if
you guys have some time to get into all
that
yeah i just
look not that not to bring us back the
young thug who may or may not have done
really stupid things like uh rent a car
that was used in a drive-by under his
own government name um
but ultimately i think like using rap
lyrics
to to tie into a ricoh case what are you
complaining that she is investigating a
guy who was involved in a drive-by
more than that but yes so what's your
problem exactly with her my problem is
that uh using rap lyrics and and it
sounds like she used the fact that he
rented a car in his name no no that part
is fine i'm talking about like uh
racketeering is already like a vague uh
it's already written in a way so that
you can actually get a mob boss yeah
locked up and not like the low-level
hitmen
you can you can turn the low-level like
street uh
like the gangsters on the street
and use them as informants to
essentially lock up the actual main
person right that's why the ricoh
charges exist because usually the boss
is multiple layers removed
um but if you turn that on uh a a record
label like uh like fanny willis did
then you can basically say like anyone
and everyone that throws up a [ __ ]
label like a gang sign because there's a
there's an association between like a
label and
and you know
street level crime uh you can just say
any rapper and every rapper is like
technically a [ __ ] criminal
um
and a gang member
and a lot of people are getting swept up
under those charges including gunna for
example which i think is like is ghana
he's for we were freeing ghana
yes i'm i'm proud
i'm pro i'm pro-free and gunner i'm
pro-freeing young pug too because you
know just why not
i'm down for him to stay in prison that
one i'm i'm a fan of you know it's
like the oj thing you know what i mean
just like you gotta
it's a mulligan
you know what i mean just one little
drive-by yeah mulligan did anyone get
hurt
uh would you yeah no people got married
oh people died yeah so that's
gonna
they may or may not have allegedly also
shot at uh lil wayne's uh tour bus too
allegedly that one's more i'm okay with
that's just kind of a vibe
like that's just kind of a vibe you know
what i mean but the other stuff trap
trap
this is the last thing i want to talk
about
not obviously flying coach is
there's nothing wrong with flying coach
don't get me wrong i'm not criticizing
anyone flying coach but the fact that
eric trump was flying clutch to
mar-a-lago is hilarious because that
means daddy didn't want to
kick down for a
for a first class or business class for
his least favorite son so i love that
for him
poor guy
where's your daddy it's just great i
mean you know donny would never fly a
coach i mean even even uh i mean junior
would never fly a car are they not do
they not have a lot of they not have a
lot of money what's going on there
that's what i'm saying bro eric trump he
he keeps his allowance pretty tight huh
daddy's a billionaire dude [ __ ] i'm
sorry but it's funny it is you know lara
is not laura trump's not [ __ ] flying
coach she's another guy where's she at
god it must suck to be such a loser
i mean is this
is this eric trump no it's been
confirmed
pictures of him in the airport in the
same outfit that's kind of wild that he
was
i mean that is kind of weird that he was
flying he's a man of the people and i
think it's definitely disrespecting yeah
no you are being so disrespectful right
now ethan this man
this man is fighting for us day in day
out yeah he's living our life
yeah
all right that's about it eh
yeah here was earlier that day thank you
yeah wearing the same outfit oh yeah
that is that's our boy and coach you
[ __ ] dad dude how much does your dad
hate you a billionaire who's all about
displaying wealth sends his son on coach
where's your daddy you were a bad boy
bad boy embarrassing cringe loser i'll
see two ah
big l major l i'll l
i'll l
yeah exactly yeah
idiot it's not top g behavior it's not
it's bottom g behavior
for sure
uh he was in new york city to oversee
the hauling of his mom's stuff from her
apartment he's wearing the same outfit
wow that's like the [ __ ] job put your
debt put your
bring her stuff to the golf course where
we buried her body that was a wild one
yeah anyway guys thanks for watching
hassan
thank you thank you for having me word
i'm not go i'm gone for two weeks uh
from leftovers at least i'll still be
live obviously but
uh but i'll be back and hopefully no
crazy stuff will happen in the process
no it'll be fun anytime i take a day off
though like [ __ ] pops off so who knows
well i'm sure we'll have plenty to talk
about when you come back in two weeks
yeah but i hope you have fun good luck
with all the stuff you're doing i hope
it goes great and uh
if you're flying are you flying
somewhere yeah are you going to be on
coach
probably not
my man
gentlemen we are all domestic terrorists
he's living campaign social media that's
like he wishes to be eric trump that's
that is actually one thing that like i
used to
i used to still like even when i had
money to upgrade i would still fly coach
and like would refuse to pay for even
like uh baggage and would contest it
like when people were like oh you have
to pay for this you have to check this
and i was like no no i don't no it's
like you weigh it taking socks out of
your overseas yeah and i'm six foot four
and also on top of that very broad so
i was i was literally torturing myself
and all these [ __ ] flights and then
one time i flew business guys i was like
oh my no economy plus i was like oh my
god
what the [ __ ] have i been doing so since
then i've been looking
bro if you could afford it there's no
reason not to i mean come on
sorry i literally cannot i cannot fit
but that's not going to play well i'm
just telling you ben spears going to
hear that you're going to have a whole
day about hassan flies first class yeah
i mean no i do i think you're doing not
first class business
business but yeah
because i don't unders dude it's so
[ __ ] up too because like
business class is basically like
you you pay
10x the price to be treated like a human
being that's like it's wild like to just
not get the cattle treatment that you
normally get in coach
or like they don't spit on your face
there's more space than you were you can
recline yeah no i just lie flat baby all
the way
love that for you i still a lot of my
friends who because like now i'm in my
30s so i have you know
uh friends not even in the entertainment
industry like friends who are very
successful in their own industries who
are
making a lot of money uh wealthy enough
to be able to buy uh you know first
class and
business class tickets and [ __ ] and i'm
always like bro what are you doing like
why don't you do that he's like no i
have a couple friends who like refuse to
do it well they're also smaller than me
they can fit in the coach it's hard to
make that leap because it is so much
more expensive it's hard it is hard to
justify sometimes it's like insanely
yeah but i don't spend money on anything
so i'm like why the [ __ ] not
you know what i mean what am i gonna do
absolutely no i support it i'm with you
man
um
listen it's been fun it's been real
uh hissing
god bless be good
yadda yadda
oh pokey's coming tomorrow pokemane
should i ask her anything really she's
doing yesterday i'm gonna be playing uh
valerant with her in a little bit she's
making her return stream today
um i'll be i'll be streaming later and
i'll be i'll be playing some val around
with her
is there anything i should ask her some
drama hmm let me think any dirt you got
on her any dirt i got them you guys are
friends right exposed pokeman
exposed um yeah i'll give you the good
stuff yeah
tell me all the dirt
no i got no i mean she's she's very good
at like
um being
a brand friendly and presenting herself
a certain way but she is she's also a
nice person i thought she was like sassy
always no she is but she does clapbacks
and stuff but like she does it in a very
she does it in a very good way that that
still um
maintains composure
love that for her
does she have her own do you feel flavor
no not not that i know of i'm pretty
sure she does not okay and that's
something to work on oh yeah
i'll give you some good stuff i'll give
you the secret sauce
actually
i don't know if we've said anything but
um we ride for gamer sub
we're like we're gamer stuff over here
big time and g phil has [ __ ] lead in
it and i would never put that [ __ ] in my
body fuel
in the words of charlie everything has
led in it technically which is true
that doesn't make it right i'm just
saying
everything what about game sub doesn't
have lead
i guess not
that's right it doesn't have that extra
oomph necessary for for gaming they say
lead it adds that a little bit of like a
little little bit of lead is good for
you yeah that's what i've heard
all right guys have fun
we'll see you guys tomorrow for after
dark friday uh well it's just we're
going to be here with pokemane tomorrow
but hassan have a good trip thank you
everyone for watching
uh peace so
mr [ __ ] is one heaping helping hunk of
a man
[Music]
you